they sell this there's a gabrielle solis  uh-huh I'm gonna I know it was to say  except a loved all there's a Gabrielle  Solis your your character they this is  available no there is it's true it's a  sex doll yeah no is that the kind of  thing where you can sue can you sue you  know what's the funny this is a new one  that is not me by the way on the package  oh you didn't you didn't pose for the  last I don't classy move on your part I  know but it was it was when we started  housewives they say sex dolls and and  and ABC shut it down really quick good  so this is a new one that's yeah but  it's good cuz you should take legal  action I will you know they keep trying  to make a Conan love doll yeah what I'm  saying we're trying to make it mean  we're trying to get interest no one  wants  [Laughter]